hey caitlin hey evan how many q a's have
we done now
a few a few but you know one group of
people we forgot to ask questions from
the most important people of all our
families our family
[Music]
so today we're going to be answering
questions that our family has about our
life
our work and the mysterious ways in
which we disappear from their lives
for days and weeks upon end while we
just dive into
our work because i think it's probably
not super common to be related to people
doing youtube and it's kind of a weird
thing and i know my family gets
questions
about like wait your daughter's a
youtuber
what is that what how does she make
money and things like that so
um yeah we thought it'd be fun to answer
our family's questions about what we do
i see uh your dad might be at first his
first question is
of course my dad starts with just like
trolling stuff
dad's first question how many inches in
your hair
first off father dearest father that
doesn't have anything to do
with what we do for a living second off
we brought a measuring tape so we can
measure
evan how long is my hair that's the
longest part right there
the back 26 inches oh
my hair is over two feet long let me
measure a few different
i need to measure a few different places
in average yeah
whoa how long is it there are you
measuring to the top 27
27 on the sides 26 in the back that
can't be right
here it's long i should probably cut it
someday yeah
yes yes please awesome
anyone watching this this is such a
strange sign maybe about 20 27 26.
there you go there you go you're you're
thank you father for exposing me
questions answered
[Laughter]
oh man how much wall space is left in
your house
not enough i mean okay um again that was
another question from my dad
um we do a lot of art projects on the
channel and we already had a lot of art
and we already had a lot in our house
before we started making more stuff for
youtube
like we we have big kind of
miscellaneous gallery walls and we we
try to just
tack stuff onto that or some things just
end up in the guest room against the
wall
and some things end up being christmas
presents so
yeah but we do have a lot of pending art
that's just ready to go that doesn't
really have a place yet
in this house what's the thing that like
you that we haven't
hung up that you want to hang the most
anything that's that urgent we've
already hung
i have one what's that the supervisor
and space art the shishugi bond oh yeah
i really like that one
it's been over a year it's because it's
so big and heavy
like we need to like really reinforce it
yeah we have a few different places
around the
house where we've just swapped things
out because there's a nail or some
screws in the wall and stuff like that
but that's a sugar bond
we're gonna have to like mount that into
some studs or something like that it's a
big boy
he's a big boy related to that um my
sister-in-law actually has a question
are there any old projects that you
really just want to throw away already
um i think the only stuff that
i've like wanted to actively get rid of
is kind of things that
either they didn't really work or they
were just more experiments like we kept
some
like resony type experiments that
you know it's like some old coasters
like our very first resin thing we just
used like a coaster mold we still have
some of those and i'm like ah do we need
it
probably not probably not we use them
for like test cuts now if we're
we we have we have gotten rid of some of
our our
past projects but there's some that like
i actually thought that i wanted to get
rid of
like our very first um the outdoor
welded table oh yeah
and then like it's been on our to-do
list for so long to
3d print some plastic feet for it we
finally did it
it looks great the reason why it looked
ugly before is because
like there was metal on the bottom and
we had just taped
with blue tape paper towels to the feet
and it didn't look great
yeah yeah and i think like i don't know
it's hard to get rid of things so like i
want space but it's not that i like
actively want to get rid of the stuff
like i feel very attached to the things
that we make because we made them you
know
even if they're kind of crappy yeah all
right we have a question from my brother
has moki ever preferred evan over
caitlyn
and for anyone who's confused moki is
jube's
formal name if you're like who's moki i
know who the supervisor is
um she has like so if we're both
often times if we're like laying on the
couch or something she goes to you
maybe because i'm warmer maybe you're
warmer
like a slightly larger lap yeah but i
think that like
most of the times if there's a choice is
caitlyn
but maybe if i smell better
if i've recently cooked food
i don't know i think she likes laying on
your she likes being in your lap when
you're when we're on the couch
yeah that's the main thing that i think
of yeah
okay so um
this is a great one from my
sister-in-law uh i assume they continue
their conversations without closing the
bathroom door
oh yeah yeah so our family sent in some
assumptions as well as questions
um yes sometimes but
more time more often we continue
conversations through the closed door
yeah we close the door close the door
but we just keep talking yeah actually
yeah we don't really ever leave it open
so there's been a lot you track it
there's been a few times where like
you're getting ready
in another room and oh and you'll leave
it open because i'm in another room and
it would be hard to hear through the
closed door yeah yeah if you're just if
you're if you're just like
if like we're like getting ready to go
out the door and we're like oh let's use
the restroom real quick
usually we just close the door and we
chat through the door but yeah if
caitlyn's in another room sometimes i'll
leave it open
for better so you can like shout
[Applause]
do you want me to get that one yeah okay
so this is
uh a fun one this is from my brother
have you shared any of our legendary
request drawings from when we were kids
um
the barbarian taking a poop comes to
mind okay so
so absolutely one of the best drawings
you've ever produced
his opinion thank you thank you um
so if on some of our twitch streams we
do request drawings it's not something
we do all the time but i will do request
drawings usually they're jube related
that stemmed originally from my brother
and i
uh because he would request something
and i would do a request drawing it's
often super fast super random
one of the first things that kicked this
off is we used to play a lot of diablo
too
and i used to i used to often draw
like the like uh fan art of video game
characters
using the little manuals that came with
the games like i did it with
diablo i did it with zelda like i would
use that as a reference to draw them big
and i don't remember how this started
but
for diablo 2 i started drawing them
literally as fast as i could with pen
just to see how they came out and it was
always hilarious and the barbarian one
because in his pose he's squatting i
made it look like he was pooping
so there was a reason so i have not
shared those specific ones
yet but i found them because i have a
notebook of all of my drawings
so to those of you who are watching the
podcast and not listening
i will i will bring up the diablo 2 ones
for those of you listening i will try to
describe it evan can describe it yeah
i'll try to describe it so caitlyn does
have
multiple three-inch thick binders of
some of her
artwork beautiful oh oh oh that's
glorious
glorious look at the pile of turds
underneath
them so this was like
uh as fast as i could draw them using
the pictures with pen
also the date is 2001.
he's great he has a glorious flowing
vein
look at his look of concentration yeah
yeah uh-huh yeah yeah look at the the
brows the brows are fur
he's dual wielding too that's great and
i like that you didn't draw like
the um the the waist
super detailed they're just like black
balls
so i think that he might need to go see
a doctor oh his poop i thought he meant
like his waist
oh no he's his poop his booty he might
need to go see the
you might need to change his diet some
he might need to he's been consuming too
much
uh oh too many enemies yeah okay i have
the sorceress
and um that's pretty that's pretty great
she's i will say
very slightly not safe for work there's
a little extra
skin showing but that's how it was in
the in the manual and i was drying
accurately look at that
she looks she looks kind of powerful she
is powerful again
flowing mane very very
accurate looking at the faces like
always get me because their faces are so
derpy she's like she's a little bit uh
but i like the girl next one
a little gaunt hey she is in the in the
in the game though i was going accurate
okay so how how long do you think you
spent on these
uh i think they're about 60 seconds each
60 seconds
honestly i'm super impressed i won't go
through all of them but i will
if i had 60 seconds to draw these
oh and and this was 19 years ago
so you know okay i'll just do one more
of them this one was a collaboration
years ago oh this is a collaboration
it looks like my brother added some
things he added some flowers on top
sprouting from his head and tail but
this is the druid and it was
one of the more complicated drawings
because there's a wolf
if you're watching this please play
close attention to the face
of of the druid and the wolf for there
i need to try to get a close-up for
their of the face
of the druid oh he looks a little bit
um zombie-ish
that's a kinder word and then the wolf
yes look at the cheeks look at the
eyelashes on that oh some eyelashes
fabulous some fur some puff yeah and
great great smiley faces right there oh
yeah from my brother
it's beautiful it's beautiful but
honestly for like 60 seconds
wow and doing it in pence you can't
erase yeah
i like how there's some uh text coming
from either the bird or him saying
you're one hot mama yeah
i don't know where that came from you
have a lot of fun doing request drawings
honestly i still have fun with it
that's that's so great um so my sister
asked what's a breakdown of a typical
day um we'll go generally
because we don't want to go into any
details because our day like is very
very irregular depending on if it's a
filming day
a streaming day an editing day you know
a planning day but we generally
wake up caitlyn wakes up earlier than i
do
wake up in the morning yeah at like
maybe 8 30
yeah gets rolling and then i get rolling
a little bit later
i'm a little bit of a slow roller and
it's because we stay up really late so
we wake up a little late we stay up a
little bit late
we get going and we usually start our
day with emails
dealing with sponsors um scheduling
things we just call it
computer productives so there's just
stuff on our computer stuff that's like
a little easy and chill to do
with some coffee when you're sleepy you
don't have to get ready yet you don't
have to
like be energetic yeah it's all of the
back end
business stuff and then honestly morning
time is very chill
i know it sounds like the more boring
stuff but i like it
yeah and just to give you a sense of
like how much time that generally takes
we do that seven days a week for for the
most of the whole morning there's always
and
evening after dinner yeah there's more
most of the time
later yeah then we'll we'll have
our first meal um which is lunch and
then after lunch usually that's
if we're gonna um create any content
it's not gonna happen until after lunch
so if we stream it's gonna be in the
afternoon if we
film we're gonna start it in the
afternoon if we
um a podcast are sometimes an exception
because like it's
the podcasts are only an hour so
sometimes we'll squeeze those and down
yeah we fit them into random spots
if we're gonna film an ad for a sponsor
we're gonna do in the afternoon because
that's when we tend to have the most
energy
and then um uh that
is often mixed in with more computer
productives or editing or
any of that stuff usually like you know
when we're not
actively filming actively creating the
podcast or actively streaming
one of us is like editing or planning
and the other one of us is doing
computer productives
um yeah it's often the same thing yeah
often the same thing um
yeah so then we'll have dinner and then
after dinner six seven dinner
yeah and then um after dinner
depending on uh how much crunch time
we're in we will either
keep making content so sometimes we
still 95
of the time we work after dinner oh yeah
we always work after dinner that's what
i'm not saying
we always work after after dinner um if
we're in super crunch mode
it'll it'll be like continuing to film
if it's not super crunch mode then it's
more computer productive it's
editing it's processing metadata it's
reviewing gaming videos and stuff like
that
yeah and about i'd say half of the day
we continue working until
11 half the day or half of the days
half of our days we probably continue
working to like eleven
the other half and maybe stop at 10 yeah
and on those days we try to work out
yeah wait we've not been hitting about
50 percent
no maybe a little uh less than in the
past three weeks we've hit like ten
percent
okay yeah so we've been working yeah we
haven't worked out very much yeah
we we started working out and we were
doing it better and
it's kind of falling just kind of but
yeah so then like
on the days where we stop closer to 10
then we have a little bit more time we
might like read or evan might
like do some pre-prepping for a gaming
stream
like hopping into minecraft or some
nautica and
like gathering some materials for a
stream um we'll go on walks
um yeah we just like we do like going
for walks we
try to take walk throughout the day too
when it's nice we try to do at least one
walk before sleep
um and we like mexican more walks
throughout
the day there's a single brief period of
the year when it's nice
yeah and that's where we do like our
meetings
you know walk meetings um and that's
pretty much seven days a week
it is literally that's that's what we do
um
you know with variations in there
depending on because some days
will be a stream day some days will be a
filming day some days it'll just be
computer productives
all day and every now and then we'll
just take a day to like
just brainstorm work on well sometimes
we'll take a day
just to like get life things done we'll
like oh yeah call the
plumber like run and get the car
registered
then like clean up the house then
grocery shop and meal prep and
um do all of the like laundry and all of
the other life miscellaneous things
yeah those kind of tend to get like
pushed off to the side until we have
enough of a lead that we can just take a
whole day and just do that all day
um that's kind of that's kind of a
typical day breakdown yeah
um so let's see um
my parents ask um what's caitlyn's
favorite comfort dinner
my favorite comfort dinner oh i might
i'm gonna have this this is a going out
one
melting pot i don't know if that
i mean i love the melting pot i don't
think that i think comfort dinner is
like when you're tired and you just want
to go grab
something oh i know caitlin's comfort
food is probably
this little japanese yeah yes
oh and like while we're there they play
like the cutest we don't go there
anymore
they played like the cutest anime music
and it was so calming
it's still playing when i go pick it up
oh and like
they have the best most comforting miso
soup and everything's so
warm they have like the best fried rice
that is like
my my feel good meal like because part
of the comfort is
just getting the food and eating it
sometimes because like
when when cooking is involved sometimes
there's like the stress of like
hot things and you get hot and like
eating it's still delicious but like
yeah when i think of a comfort dinner i
usually don't think of having to cook
even though i like cooking yeah and some
of our meals are
very comforting yeah you know probably
like if i was gonna pick a at-home meal
that's a comfort dinner it'd probably be
cheesy pasta and broccoli the magic
broccoli that's like
my comfort dinner yeah all right wait
what about you oh for me
come for dinner um
it's only rarely that it happens but
like i'd say
um that japanese restaurant also but
also
like specifically i'm cheating here but
thanksgiving and christmas videos oh
yeah you know i mean
that was hard to top that's hard to top
also because
every time after i eat a big meal like
that i just go and
like semi nap afterwards yeah and those
might be associated but eating a whole
bunch of food and just napping a little
bit
that's pretty comforting that's pretty
comforting
oh okay so here's a question from my mom
what is the current state of the guest
room now that no one is likely to be
visiting
okay guys it's bad
it's bad it has gotten better
actually um uh for some context
i think it was a about a year-ish ago or
maybe at the beginning of
2020 we re did our guest room some
um we did a little bit of a makeover we
already do have like a murphy bed
in there so that helps save some space
but it just started
filling up with extra stuff a lot of
like filming gear
lighting backdrop stuff things that take
up
a decent amount of space and like like
some workout gear
um just like
in like a month ago we ordered some
shelving
um to help us wrangle all of the
camera and filming stuff um so we've
added some giant
shelves to it you could still pull out
the murphy bed but yeah like within
within 10 minutes we could have the
murphy bed down
yeah with it i mean only if we moved all
the junk to the living room
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it sounds
usable yeah so
it's worse than when you guys saw it on
our youtube video
but it's better than it was earlier
during quarantine yeah okay this is
great your dad
asks have you ever farted on camera and
accidentally left it in
i don't think so i mean if i
accidentally left it in i think someone
would tell
yeah glove parts yeah yeah no i don't
think we have
oh here's a related one again from my
dear
loving father when you live streamed
underwater how many times did you pee
so we were live streaming for what like
how long was the actual stream
two hours two was it two i couldn't
remember it was two or three hours
i was way too nervous to pee
i don't think i did
because it was just like i don't know
yeah just pure adrenaline
such adrenaline and i don't think i
think i'd purposely not
drink enough yeah i wasn't i wasn't
drinking enough
beforehand because i was really paranoid
about having to pee
because it would have been such a hassle
to like get out of your scuba gear
and get out of the pool and then get all
re-hooked up with the mat the fancy mask
and scooby gear
and all of that so i really didn't want
to have to pee
so my brother asks if we had an
unlimited budget for a single maker
project what would it be
oh that's great that's easy we're going
to lose use the loophole because
building a house yeah that's a maker
project house and workshop new housing
housing workshop
like i actually recently bought a
program
that helps you design houses maybe we'll
turn that into a video we'll design our
dream workshop and house or something
that'd be fun that'd be fun we'll see i
don't know
but yeah would definitely use it to
build our house and workshop because
that's going to be the most expensive
thing we ever do
and it's going to be the most worth it
thing we ever do
so that'll be fun so my parents ask when
will the novelty of your work wear off
enough that you'll be willing to cut
back
further and make changes in your
lifestyle
so i think um i think it's not so much a
matter of
novelty wearing off actually yeah it's
kind of like
pressure to ride the wave if that makes
sense
kind of somewhat pressure to ride the
wave because like
when things are going well you got to
keep up that momentum
um i don't know if novelty is
the is really the thing there because
we've been doing it for almost four
years now
and i think if it was just novelty it
would have worn off after
hundreds of videos yeah and if it's
really the novelty we can just change
the type of videos we're making we can
try a different technique we can try
you know there's like lots of ways to
keep things novel that's true
but so i think um i think we've actually
already cut
back a lot um
in some ways and we've added new things
in other ways so our main
channel we used to do four to six
sometimes videos a month um and we've
uh for this year done even though we've
had a couple
months where we did it every month for
the most part has been either
two or three times a month um and we
planned to continue that
in 2021 um the gaming is what we added
so we do spend a lot more time
streaming and now we've added like you
know along with the this it's kind of
just streaming has been
generalized because it used to be just
games now we're doing workshop streams
too
um so it has kind of spread out and
spilled over to more channels
yeah so we put more time into that um
but i think another huge way in which
we've pulled back too
is we've been going for just very
interesting videos that we find really
interesting that
we'll have fun with and that will make
for good videos instead of us doing a
big project
just because it's big time consuming
doesn't necessarily equate to
a good video from the audience
perspective or our
enjoyment perspective so yeah because we
used to have much more
physically large builds which um
uh you know in the maker community a lot
of times it's like you build a bigger
thing
that's probably gonna get more views
like a dining table or a bed
yeah or stuff stuff like that is gonna
get more views than like a tiny
plant stand for example or you know i'm
just kind of pulling out some examples
but
um i think as we've uh become
more about entertainment and less about
instruction it's not so much about the
size of the the project idea
yeah and sometimes honestly when we try
to fit too many ideas into a single
video
like if we had a resin rainbow
holographic wireless charging
transforming
side table build like that'd be
it's like too confusing and you couldn't
fit that
concept into a title and thumbnail and
it's almost better to break it down a
little bit yeah it is
more enjoyable for us too way more
enjoyable way more enjoyable
so i think that like you know it's not
when will the novelty of your work work
off that you'll be
willing to cut back further and make
changes in your lifestyle
we are prioritizing our lifestyle
because like we described
to my sister earlier we work a lot
and we really like having a little bit
of breathing room
not just because it's enjoyable for us
but we because we have also found that
having a little bit of breathing room
is so beneficial to our
content creation in general better ideas
we have more energy we're having more
fun we have
room for things to sit and grow and
iterate in our heads instead of just
running
like well we can't we don't have any
time to think of any ideas we'll just do
this one
even though it might not be the best one
that used to honestly be how things
worked
well we used to we used to like we would
publish a video on friday
and we would start next friday's video
like
on the saturday after publishing the
last one like now we try to work more
ahead we're usually
a week or two ahead um so anything that
you're seeing on youtube
was filmed a week or two ago and some
when we're really on top of things that
might be filmed three weeks ago it's
been a while since we were at that point
yeah okay a question from my mom um
i know you have names used when
referring to different tasks you guys do
throughout the
day slash week like couch productives
computer productives they sound very
professional but i'm not sure what
exactly they entail
i guess we sort of uh answered what like
computer productives are
yeah it's basically just our name for
like literally anything on the computer
where we're not like our tasks are kind
of divided into like
tiers of energy they require yeah tears
of energy
that's it like content creation as you
know for that that's like filming
streaming podcasting it requires the
most energy and it remains the most
energy yeah requires most energy drains
the most energy
the next level is like computer
productives yeah you know that can be
editing
emailing sponsors it's like you need
your brain for it
um but it you don't have to be outwardly
energetic to do it
the next tier is couch production and
that's when you're
really tired you need to lay down on the
couch you still kind of want to be
productive
so that's like um liking comments yeah
that's like like replying to comments on
social media
that's improving held moderation things
yeah yeah yeah
it's like there's just really a handful
of things sometimes you know we'll still
take a computer over
it might be like you know reviewing some
stuff
i don't know it's just kind of like the
lowest
the most like we don't need our fancy
computers to process anything we don't
need that much brain power
but we feel guilty not being productive
a question from your dad also who snores
the loudest and who talks in their sleep
the most
you snore i snore a little bit yeah i'm
sorry
usually i'll just like put my hand on
you or something then you're like
and then you'll stop so it's not too bad
um caitlyn
do i talk in my sleep like makes
noises in her sleep like she's reacting
to things
yeah yeah
i'm like a minecraft villager
yeah so me i i i i i'll call that one
it's not too bad though not too bad um
so
an assumption from my brother i assume
they have some sort of lovey-dovey
phrase they say each night before going
to sleep
kind of i think that like that the
biggest thing phrase no it's like
we kind of like affirm that today was a
good day
we were like i'm really proud of us we
did a lot together like this was really
cool
so we're doing this together yeah we
kind of like affirm
that we're on the right path kind of
yeah we do like pretty much every day we
never did that consciously that never
like happened
no it wasn't like we should start like
saying what things we did good
throughout the day to like remind
ourselves like it wasn't like a
it wasn't like that it was more just
like feeling proud of what we did and
wanting to express that to someone and
like
you can't also we don't stop until bed
yeah we don't stop until then
and so and it's kind of hard you know
you can't just like text your friends
and be like hey guys
i did some really great stuff today you
know what i mean when you're working
with your friend all day you can't say
yeah you can be like wow great stuff
great
and then it's not bragging because
you're congratulating each other so it's
harder for you to do that to
to yourself but like when you're doing
it as a group and you're congratulating
like
the group effort it is really great then
we say like you know
hope you sleep well love you yeah and
i'm trying to think of like if there's
like a little like specifically cute
lovey-dovey phrase
we don't catch it all the time but
eleven eleven
oh yeah eleven eleven which is what we
that's you know when it's eleven eleven
that when the time is eleven eleven you
make a wish and we both have like the
same wish we've been
like making since we first started
dating we told each other wishes
basically the same wish and we still
keep making it it's very cute
i like it yeah um and you know there's
like the various weird things
like i'm not sure if they're cute or
lovey-dovey but we just do weird noises
at each other
a lot yeah it does that there's that but
yeah at night specifically i think that
the thing that's
maybe different that we do is like the
lots of like positive affirmations good
stuff we did today good stuff
because it's it is great okay another
question from my brother um this is a
little bit of a long one
so lots of people do things they find
enjoyable to distract themselves from
focusing on work
because they don't really like their
work with that said you both seem like
you really enjoy
your work so what i wonder is has your
work ever served to distract you from
doing something
outside your career that you think you
should be doing
and i think yes i think probably yes
i think it's really easy for us to put
off typical life tasks
because we gotta we gotta film this
video you know like how long have we
been putting off getting the car
inspected we still have time we still
have some time
12 days of 12 days but it's been at
least 12 days already you know things
like that or like
it's tough because getting something
fixed on the house yeah it's tough
because
we do kind of like it is
us taking this on and some things we
don't need to
but there is like a certain schedule we
have set
that does take a long time to bring back
down to reasonable levels
um but yeah that's definitely true
because we do enjoy it
we are excited about it it benefits us
greatly
and you know it's such a good fit for
like
what we would naturally want to do yeah
it was a perfect excuse to not do that
thing around the house that we've been
meaning to do for a
long time yeah but we also like cleaning
and organizing and getting our house put
together so i like cleaning and
organizing but i don't like setting up
appointments for like oh we got to set
up an appointment for someone to
come and fix this thing on the house so
yeah we have to like oh we need to trim
our trees
you know like
i don't really enjoy that stuff so it's
really easy to use work as an excuse to
put it off
yeah that's very true that's very true
so
my my sister asked what's on our bucket
list
list more travel
i guess so i mean i it would be fun i i
like
but it's also what's on my bucket list
is like finding the person that i want
to spend the rest
of my life with and spending a lot of
time with that person
yeah it's it's interesting because i
think i often think of bucket list
things as like
i don't know like someday we'll do that
a lot of the
like important things i feel really
grateful to have figured out and like
really enjoy um so yeah i mean i think
it'd be fun to travel but i don't
it's not one of those things that like
one day i'll i'll get to do that
it's like oh i guess like if we get if
we free up some time and we get kind of
bored of doing this we could travel some
no yeah i think that that is a big thing
that's interesting when
we used to have pining for it when we
used to have more traditional jobs
we wanted vacations more we wanted
travel more and all of that
and not that that's not fun but i think
one of the big reasons why we wanted
that
is because it meant not working yeah and
it meant doing something much much much
better
yeah we get to do something great very
frequently and we enjoy this a ton
um now at the same time i will say
bucket list is having an amazing house
with a great view with a great big
workshop in the back
everything's set up everything organized
neat precise
systems in place like bucket list is now
like
a location to get to yeah but but that's
also interesting because like
i feel like bucket list is such a i
don't know i feel like that's like
you know a goal for the within the next
couple years that's like something that
like we will
probably do but at the same time
something like that
has been on my like bucket list it's
more like a
life ambition long-term life goal to do
something like this
is to have an amazing workshop with
everything there and i can make anything
at any time i've said it multiple times
going back in the podcast but i think
that is like a bucket list
level idea yeah to have that
in the to have that available
is like my like it's been kind of like
an end goal of mine like
that and here's here's an interesting
thing
i feel like when i think of bucket list
i think of like
you go do that thing and then it is done
you know what i mean it's like skydive
or travel to this place yeah but
wouldn't you just rather have something
that's great that lasts
no no
yeah and so i think that's why i have
trouble coming up with it it's not that
there's not things i want to do but it's
like most the stuff that i'm most
excited about
is stuff that are like points in life to
get to
yeah more not that the other stuff
wouldn't be fun
you know what i think that we could
throw like you know we like
we don't you know we could go off on a
big side tangent on this but like
maybe on our bucket list are like
meeting other
uh content creators see but that's not
we've met other content creators
like you know maybe like some some
people in particular that's not a bucket
list that's just like it'd be nice in
the future to do that
bucket list i have to do this before i
die i need to accomplish this task
meeting other content creators it's like
hey it'd be nice to continue
stretching your bucket list circle of
like content cr
social circle of content creators yeah
we have some content creator friends
it'd be great to meet new content
creator friends that's not vocal bug
less
bucket list is like i want to skydive
you know what we have skype
yeah but you know what it's interesting
i was like we we probably should skydive
this is the best time to do it i want to
experience it but it was never real like
we did it
it wasn't actually a bucket list it was
more like
we're in new zealand we should if we're
ever going to skydive we should probably
do it now
but you know what's weird i think this
is uh illustration of the type of people
we are
we plan our lives and our goals
and our ambitions around things that
will sustain
and not be just a spike of joy and not
just be a spike of joy yeah and that's
why we
buckled down and made this channel
that's why we're working so hard that's
why like
you know we could go out and enjoy
things that are enjoyable that we'd like
but we know that
setting up this long-term enjoyment
system will optimize our happiness the
most
and for us for us personally this is
like you know it's like of course it's a
very personal thing
well and i mean the way you're worrying
it sounds like it's like oh we just
gotta do all this work now and
eventually we'll be happy
but no it's like the act of setting it
up the act of
creating what we create we love systems
very fun but yeah both setting up
systems like we like we love like future
proofing things but we also
like the day-to-day of like doing a
stream doing a podcast making a video
like we enjoy all of that but yeah
it's it's honestly kind of hard to think
of bucket list items it's like i got
like i want to go on more vacations
eventually yeah but i don't have like
the passion
for that and it's also like it's not
that unattainable
yeah so it it's not like some pie in the
sky like one day
i'm gonna
i don't know climb machu picchu
yeah well a lot of people do that you
mean like mount everest mount everest
yeah but honestly i so don't want that
mount everest we we climbed like uh
we did an alpine crossing in new zealand
which almost destroyed us yes
i'm good you know um all right moving on
uh my parents asked uh
how will you say how will you stay
humble grounded and
non-self-centered as you become bigger
celebrities
we have each other also the weird
celebrities
the word celebrity i just think of like
traditional celebrities so it's very
weird
it's it's um yeah
i think like we think that there is some
risk
of there is risk like you know people
who
blow up either either in social media or
whatever
like losing sight of
like losing perspective perhaps not
everyone does it for sure not everyone
doesn't
um most probably don't i know like you
know there's a ton of huge people that
haven't lost perspective yeah but i
think there is a danger
um especially potentially if
you get isolated or something or i think
it also
on the opposite spectrum it might depend
on who you surround yourself with
like what kind of influences you
surround yourself with i i think for us
like another thing is um
we didn't even consider youtube
until we were fully formed adults
we had already you know
you know gone to high school gone to
college worked summer jobs
worked corporate jobs for several years
like
bought a house gotten married like we
knew
we knew who we were and we our
personalities were already formed
before we had this amount of attention
that
most humans don't have on us another big
thing that i think will will be a factor
in in whether or not that that gets to
people
why they did it yeah like why did
like why did you start youtubers
pursuing
your career as a content creator for the
two of us it's that we can spend time
together so we can be creative
so we like you know making and sharing
that with a large group of people
is something we enjoy but the main
motivation
is for us to be together and have fun
and live the best life that we can
and that's turned out to be enjoyable
for other people to watch that's great
it's it's been a great you know success
all around i think you know and i'm
really happy with where things are
where they're going but we've never lost
sight
that the most important thing is that
we are having fun together yeah and
that's
yeah the most important thing and we're
not pursuing anything for
like fame reasons
yeah and i feel like if you get stuck
pursuing that
yeah you might have a higher chance of
falling down that path
and it's like as a caveat to a certain
extent
like when you're in
content creation or social media like
having a successful channel equates to
having some level of quote-unquote
fame because like you have to have
viewers to make
money doing it as a business so like
to us up to a certain point they are
tied but like
we quit our full time we were fully
quitted from our full-time jobs at like
80
000 subs like if we were still
at that point like we'd be okay because
we were making enough to like
feel comfortable quitting our jobs and
we're spending time together doing great
stuff
you know um so
yeah yeah i think that that covers that
pretty well
so your mom asks what percentage of time
what percentage of time even when
filming from the waist up are you
wearing your comfy pants and is evan
wearing shorts and flip-flops
i'm wearing my comfy pants now evan is
wearing
comfy socks and my shorts shorts and
comfy socks um i would say
probably 100 no there are some things
where i will put on jeans
yeah and i'll sometimes put on like real
clothes too yeah but
probably 90 of the time that you
see that you guys are seeing me i'm in
comfy pants
the same pair of cups they're really
they are your mom yeah for christmas
last year
that's like literally my 2020 uniform
has been these
specific comfy
that pants great so do you want to
answer a really hard hitting
oh yeah a question from my dad who's
your favorite father
dad i love you you're you're my favorite
father thanks for thanks for throwing me
that softball
okay but for real do you and evan ever
see taking time completely off of work
like fully disconnecting
i mean we like
occasionally we'll take like a two-day
trip
like an overnight trip yeah we do maybe
once a year
twice a year if you include holidays
three times a year twice a year
if you include holidays that we are
okay but like you know when we when we
take time off for holidays we don't
we're not fully disconnected that's
the only time i've really been fully
disconnected
like the most we've ever been
disconnected is when we take like
a two-day retreat to like and we
brainstorm ideas for work on but we
don't
we don't check our phones we don't check
our phones we don't
work we think we think
but that's the most we've ever been
disconnected since starting
since starting and let's say in the past
four years almost
we've done three of those yeah those
little two day trips those little two
day trips other than that
it's just been work you know we took a
few families family vacation for family
reunions which is usually like
three days that's harder to work during
yeah
yeah that's harder to work during so
maybe like we have we have one of those
a year
aside from dude let's generalistically
toss it up to like
10 10 days off oh
like 10 different times in the past
four years something like that something
like that
it's not good it's not great but will we
ever
take time completely off of work you
know what that's an interesting question
because
we put in our calendar that like like
have we done it yet no we've only
missed two we've only scheduled two
we've only missed two out of two we we
but one day
one day a month we've put on there to
take that day off
yeah one of them was on one of our
birthdays and then we were like we
should do this once a month this was
great
and we didn't we only semi took it off
we like kind of took a break and then we
did some like around the house stuff
that we had like
that we wanted to do not like boring we
watched a movie though
yeah we like watched a movie and we like
i think that might be when we bought the
shelves
i'm not sure yeah cause like i don't we
like
organizing it's fun um and again we put
it on the calendar
to once a month not do any like evan and
katelyn
business work that day yes we
have not done
that check back in a few months
all right so my brother assumes that
when we had one million youtube
subscribers
shortly thanks to you for noticing
that's very exciting coming up
um they will have a nice dinner and
celebrate briefly before going back to
work on the next video
yeah yeah yeah we'll order something out
from a nice place oh
i know the place i want that yeah yeah
yeah you know the place we'll get some
takeout
and that'll probably
be it i mean it's weird it's kind of
like birthdays as an adult like we're
super excited it's like a crazy number
but also like going the difference of
like that one
extra subscriber you're very close i
kind of disagree
if we had more time yeah that's true we
probably would do more
yeah if we had more time i would want to
do more just the two of us
yeah if we had more time and it was safe
to gather socially
yeah i think that we might do something
i think that i really do want you to
mark that moment you're true we should
just we can
yeah but the reality that we can't
ignore
because we are responsible people mm-hmm
and
and go do stuff caitlyn is the type of
person if she got a work assignment
for school she would do it as soon as
she can and if she has extra work
afterwards
that is when you spend your free time oh
if i had extra time afterwards yeah if
you had
yeah if you had extra time afterwards
then you can use that recreationally yes
and i really wasn't that way
but you kind of are now i kind of am now
and it's because
it just makes sense as a content creator
you just gotta like work and get it done
as soon as you can
and in a way we do have a finite amount
of work we have infinite work
that we can create for ourselves but on
our schedule we have a finite amount of
work
and if you put it off it's way worse
yes it's so much worse in every way no i
think that's not really the biggest
part about why a celebration of one
million
might not be that big because like
you for something important you can put
off like we
in most cases can't put off work for
like half a day or something
yeah but it's kind of like if if
everyone's gonna be putting one off for
half a day
you could go do i was gonna say like if
it wasn't you know
20 20. yeah you could go do so like we
could like
go to the spa and have like a relaxing
spa day we could go have brunch
yeah brunch and spa
yeah maybe do other nice things
also like one day when we have more time
we'll
be able to think of those nice things um
but no i i
like the thing is also i think the other
part of it is we enjoy what we're doing
yeah so we just want to do more yeah i
think that that's a big part of it too
yeah yeah so um
let's see my sister asks what are your
favorite and least projects favorite and
least favorite projects and why
i think we've been asked that question a
few times on other podcasts has it
changed since then
i think our favorite is still the things
we use the most
the garage reorganization this podcast
desk
the things that we use honestly it's
hard to it's hard to think about because
there's so many
projects there's so many projects least
favorite there's also
favorite least favorite as in like the
how enjoyable was the process
of making it yeah versus how much do you
enjoy the results
yeah because there's some things where
like i like the result but it wasn't
yeah well let's answer it let's answer
in that way the the
most fun project video we've ever done
blind baking
that was hilarious yeah the blind baking
of banana muffins
we had so much we had so much fun
filming that caitlyn had a ton of fun
editing it
that was great that was probably our
most favorite project in terms of the
like work yeah and i think
the like least favorites oh maybe the
very first bob ross no i had fun with
that one
in terms of doing it i mean we were a
little stressed because we were like oh
man was this video even going to be good
yeah i think that that's what i was
thinking i was stressed it took so long
we didn't even know if it was good and
then you took you had to take such a
long time editing it
that's true but i was gonna say actually
like just some of the
bigger projects we've done where there's
so much like behind the scenes
that just takes forever to do
there are some least favorite moments
that i can shout out
the resin knives the ring oh yeah the
resin knives polishing the resin
oh oh and we found the scene where i
broke it right yeah
we didn't keep the scene where i sprayed
the one with acetone no
oh yeah and you accidentally messed up
the finish and then had to repolish the
whole thing yeah i don't know
we sometimes like when there's just too
much pain
and it just doesn't really add to the
flow or there's already been so much
pain
so much pain and it just like messes
with the video
sometimes like but
unenjoyable as a whole because pouring
the resin right seeing those pieces
being cut out of the scene
so many parts so fun
like it's the tasks like polishing
like uh mundane woodworking
like some of that stuff can just get and
i think we're lucky to say this but i
don't think that there's any
project that i could say was a negative
experience as a whole
i don't think so i mean not that it's
popping into my head yeah also
because that wouldn't make for a good
video yeah yeah if we were having a
really bad time it wouldn't be a good
thing it would not be
good sometimes we can have a somewhat
bad time in certain moments and it makes
for a
fun moment because it's like a challenge
yeah so my parents say uh we love your
chemistry and love for each other
how do you see that changing over your
lifetime i mean we've already known each
other
since we were like 18 so
let's not put numbers on there
we've known each other for a long time
we've known each other for a long time
so you know i think that like how do we
see that changing over time
increasing our telepathy yes because
caitlyn already has
great telepathy for me i have pretty
good lovely telepathy for you
yeah like increasing our inside jokes
and lore
just gonna continue to increase over
time deepening it we always have we
already have like a ton of weird things
we say
i think one interesting thing of like
since starting the channel
is um we have like like we're often
even more impressed by each other like
like we were setting up for a garage
stream and i walked out and i'm just
like there's
like this crazy complicated setup and
i'm just like you are so good
look at what you've set up this is
amazing you know and like we're hit
even more often by those things because
we're working together we we film what i
worry is a
garbage video and caitlyn makes this
masterful piece of art from it and i'm
like
i don't understand how you do that one
time i tried to like re
like help one of our edit editors
re-edit this one
scene to kind of like help them like on
a gaming
on a gaming video so so caitlin edits
all of our main videos our we have
five wonderful editors that help us with
our gaming um edit and usually we don't
have any changes occasionally we'll have
like little tweaks
and sometimes like when we're giving
feedback on the timing of like
little things caitlyn we'll just like
whip up like a little
mock-up of how she kind of sees things
flowing to kind of give them a better
understanding of the timing that we are
hoping for in a scene like that
and i try to do it once oh my gosh i
spent like
three hours like so frustrated and going
down
all these rabbit holes and i'm like oh
maybe i'll try like
maybe i'll try adding this like fun
thing or maybe i'll rearrange it in this
way or that way or that way
and caitlyn just knocked it out really
well in like 10 minutes
it was i'm sorry you had to go through
the frustrations i want to
understand maybe i'll like
try doing a rough cut one day no but you
don't even like
like your your editing has evolved to
the point where you do a
90 edit right from the beginning now
sometimes almost 100 edited yeah
yeah i don't even really rough cut it
you don't even really rough cut so it's
like mine might just like mess you up
more
yeah because you'd be curious about what
i cut out i know because sometimes
sometimes i'll take awkward bits yeah
you'll need that like
awkward pause and leave it in for
dramatic or
comedic effects so yeah
so how do we see that changing over time
we just see it getting awesomer
um so what past projects are up for
grabs as christmas presents your mom
asked you'll find out mom
you can't sneak that from information
from
us um also she has
if when evan cuts her hair assuming it
goes well can you cut mine too
no no no no no it's already enough
pressure yeah
yeah and she has so much
spare hair i have yeah i have so much
spare length if he if he botches it
like you know i can just throw it up in
a ponytail
and it'll be fine maybe watch him do
mine first
so i think that this is a great thing to
wrap things up with
your dad asks what do you want to do
more of
i mean aside from having a slightly
better balance which
we are already working on 2021's
schedule
and working that in to do less videos so
like i want a little bit more time i
want to do
more garage streams i've really been
enjoying those i want to do more garage
streams
i want to do more main channel videos
that are so i'll use
our most recent one as an example where
we did the um
diffraction grading resin rainbow
experiment
i want to do more videos that
we can kind of film more casually and
film
in a more real-time way um
that video like
i'm trying to think the best way to
explain this so like for any video
there's a certain amount of time you put
in
to make the project happen and a certain
amount of output of like finished video
you get um for something where there's a
like a ton of sanding or a ton of
polishing or a ton of repeated tasks or
a ton of time lapsing or a ton of
wait time there's a whole lot of work
you have to do
that doesn't lead to any good content
it's necessary
for the video but it's not as fun it's
like repetitive it's often
more boring it takes a long time so i
want to do more videos that are kind of
more
real time like what you're seeing and
edit is closer to what it was like in
real life because those are really fun
to film we just like turn on the camera
and we do it
instead of it's spanning a week with a
ton of stuff that has to be done off
camera because it's just
not as exciting yeah yeah and that takes
a lot more brainstorming
yeah those are harder ideas to come up
with because you don't
want to do i mean yeah we could just be
like we're gonna
you know i don't know the best example
yeah but they do take
longer to come up with for us yeah i
think for me
what do i want to do more of i have
loved our trajectory
you know we we started with just one
youtube
channel we um you know
have moved it in the direction that we
want and the best way to summarize
everything that i want for the future
because there's a ton
that i want to do more of we i have we
have some great ideas
for main channel videos we have some
great ideas for
um you know our gaming channel we have
great ideas for
videos that we don't know where they fit
honestly honestly a lot of those
that is something i want to figure out
how to do those videos but i think that
the thing is
we have been moving in a direction
that i enjoy that i feel is right
and we have been moving our life in that
better direction too
where we have a little bit more free
time we have more systems i just want to
like
optimize our life optimize our
technology
optimize our like storage i want to
optimize our videos
i want to like optimize all these things
i want to keep on
actively steering our life and our
content
because that's what's allowed us to get
here and
we can't i can't point in a single
direction
and say there that's where i want to go
because as we have
been moving our life
content wise lifewise all of that
we get to a place and then we evaluate
what do we like about where we were
where do we like about where we've gone
do we need to step back is this the
right direction do we need to turn left
right whatever
it's kind of like we're like wandering
in a fog
kind of and it's kind of like you you
can't
see all the way there so you need to
constantly evaluate and i think that's
what i want to keep on doing
yeah um
and i think that's the best way to
summarize all my thoughts
yeah that was a very good non-answer
answer
no but it's just the answer okay okay
okay
well um big shout out to our families we
love you very much
thank you for sending us questions for
sending us questions it's really
interesting to get
your thoughts and because like we talk
to our families about
about what we do but there's just some
stuff that doesn't may not naturally
come up
yeah i mean it'd be kind of weird to say
like so what questions do you have about
our work
in the normal like just think of a
normal conversation and just drop that
in
yeah and that would be like oh well let
me think for a little bit
you know it's tough to just come up with
questions right there so thanks for
taking time
out of your days to send us questions
appreciate it um
and now that we have answered some
questions hopefully well
it's time for thing of the week
so my thing of the week um
uh is the game theory video
about unasaunas and if you
were unaware of what asanas is then this
is not
gonna make sense to you at all a little
bit later if if you were a fan
like we were i say were because it's no
longer around
um the game theory of video is very
interesting we can still
be fans of unicornis oh yeah that's true
yeah the concept the memories the
memories memento
yeah yeah um but yeah so uh
if you're a fan the game theory video
about uh if you're a fan
[Music]
it's a very interesting video to like
analyze the lore and the secret messages
and stuff and you know some of it
uh like now that the channel is over
you know some things maybe were
confirmed or not confirmed but it's
still just very interesting
so that's my recommendation we'll have a
link my thing of the week is uh
it was a small part of our resident wood
computer build
that didn't really make it into the
video it only it made it into the
patreon after show
ah okay yeah so i'll we'll talk about a
little bit here
um the top glass of that
had a iridescent i'm not sure the right
word to describe it it's like
like unicorn holographic iridescent film
i don't know the
best way to describe it but it's color
shifting multiple multiple colors
purple blue gold pink
hue shifting it's semi-transparent it's
mostly transparent
some semi-mirrored but it's a film that
you attach
you you spray soapy water you apply this
film you squeegee the water out
um and like over a period of time i'm
not sure the best way to do it i'm we're
still very newest
the first time yeah but it was cool
it looks so it looks awesome and it's
it's a very unique thing um maybe i'm
not sure if we could do a whole video
about it
we couldn't maybe we found a bunch of
interesting stuff to apply it to
yeah maybe but like applying iridescent
film to everything in our house
little thing and like we've been
brainstorming like what else can we put
this on the stuff is so cool
you can maybe embed it in resin or
something like that i feel like we had
some specific ideas
yeah i don't remember what they are it
would have been great for the pop socket
um that would have been a great resource
to have there
but anyways it's just a neat little yeah
thing you can add your crafts perhaps um
yeah and uh that would share that
because it's a neat thing
we'll have a link to it below yeah well
i hope you guys enjoyed
today's uh podcast uh
do you want me to step in if you enjoyed
it
if you enjoyed it i was trying to think
like if there's any like
thing else we could add like questions
like that our audience could ask us
about this or
people are always open to your questions
and occasionally we gather them all up
and do q and a so if you guys have
questions you can always leave them yeah
don't know when our next q a will be
it might be wild yeah it doesn't hurt to
leave questions but
thank you guys for listening and for
hanging out with us we appreciate
five-star reviews on anything
you might be listening to oh wow
this is caitlyn's first time doing the
five starfish go go go uh yeah our goal
is to is to to prank the podcast
community into finding our podcast and
not knowing who we are because
our wonderful listeners all give us five
star reviews and we go up in the charts
and then they're just like who are these
people
they're offering nothing of value i'm so
papa pranked right now
um that's our pitch give us five star
reviews that was great that was a great
that was a great pitch thank you thank
you good podcast
see you next time
we're still here probably yeah we're
still here